hey guys Justine and James video is a
little different and he's not that
different I've definitely done these
videos before somebody tweeted me this
on Twitter and I said what is it how do
I get it where do I find it I went to
Amazon I bought them and I love kettle
corn so much he's like my favorite
tastes like it's just something about
the sweetness and just the popcorn and
the crunch some good kettle corn it is
unlike anything ever when I saw this
come through my Twitter timeline
obviously you know what I did well what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do a little
taste test two cookies is a hundred and
fifty calories okay I'm just gonna
forget that I saw that anyway moving on
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do a
taste test and I'm gonna see what they
taste like and then I'm gonna bring my
sister in and I'm gonna see if she can
guess what flavor Oreo this is so first
my friends let's open it up I would love
to know from you guys because there are
so many flavors of Oreos that it's
honestly so overwhelming what is your
favorite flavor do you like just basic
ones or the lift and taste oh good
here's what they look like they just
look like everyday basic Oreos so I go
[Music]
occasionally phenomenal what does it
taste like kettle corn I'm not sure for
research research does not count
calories at all so my research is
concluding let's doesn't taste like
kettle corn
but whatever it does taste like like a
slight like butterscotch maybe kind of
flavor it's really good I would eat this
entire container so 10 servings slimmies
there's 20 cookies
what is 20 times 150 the answer is 3000
this is only 3000 calories this was like
what I would eat in a day but I would
just have to hope you don't miss I'm
gonna go get Jetta I need a five you
because I don't want her to even see the
packaging I don't want her to see that
it's a golden Oreo I want her to come in
here actually blindfold it we're here
Jenna's here let's get it in here I've
got you this nice little blindfold I saw
that on your bathtub yes I brought it
over here because you're gonna put that
on and I have a taste test for you it's
something disgusting I promise it's
gonna be delicious
oh okay it matches me very dear yes okay
looks like you as a Jenna Myles is it
about a mouse I'm sure what do you think
it is I can't see it Oh help yourself to
one holds a smell also as you can't see
her it's not like a waffle oh it does
not wash
it doesn't like we could make them start
kind of actually have you have one yet I
have so uh you're looking at now see you
are wild your relief this is an
investigative reporter one person I try
it I chased I loved it actually this
doesn't taste like a chocolate cookie it
tastes like the other cookie no I'm not
I'm not going to save you're right or
you're wrong it doesn't taste chocolate
did you miss your mouth oh good this is
a quality conflict that you come here
and subscribe for okay it just tastes
like it tastes like a waffle well it's
not a waffle it is definitely not a
while thank you no it has puffed millet
pieces inside what the heck is a puffed
millet I don't even know let me look it
up was that crunch it was that a puffed
millet I've talked to millet what the
heck is a puffed millet it's like an
all-natural cereal oh should I be
thinking cereal flavored it's not really
a bright I mean you could eat it for
breakfast but that's weird it was a
puffed millet pieces but that was their
decision someone decided that I don't
know what that is like a like a puffed
like a puffed millet like a puffed
millet it's like puffed like you like
like a pop I would like I would picture
like a puffed corn oh I completely
messed up I just basically gave you the
answer
oh I had wine horn let's do it over we
have to delete it we're deleting this
we're starting over act like you've
never seen this act like this never
happened it doesn't taste like a waffle
it does it has come you didn't tell me
I'm exposed for you videos you're
exposed puffed millet puffed millet
daddy I am Ella boil in pieces this is a
now that you have your eyes let me show
you kettle corn puffed rice is what I
meant
wow I'm learning so it is well this is
puffed corn I tasted like making sure I
completely gave you the answer I love
Oreos it's good that I really like them
these are like this is I love the golden
Oreos so I think the golden my Oreo
creation vote for your favorite what's
your favorite Oreo
I love the birthday cake well oh he owes
are good I'll break out the red velvet
also good he's kind of like basically oh
me too I like the thin ones so I can eat
more of them oh my gosh they had they
had something else it was like in a bag
it was Oreo bites or something but they
were the ones that were covered in like
the chocolate and the white chocolate
but they were White's ha and I was like
no there's so many Oreo thing it's like
Oreo flavored or you just fit were you
as a lifestyle change the choice is
choice that I like well I did really
enjoy these a lot to see what the millet
looks like let's give them us a look at
the millet looks like well really see a
good millet P oh well it needs a minute
millet that's so that's a millet you
heard it here first junior if it has a
taste I would like to know how many of
you guys knew what a millet hmm well
it's like a grain because I've
definitely yeah it's the type of grain
usually sold it as a breakfast cereal
okay you shouldn't
well it's low-fat it's also gluten-free
it's making it a nutritious option for
people who are gluten intolerant they
can stop eating sugar left brains have
been made for centuries with the
simplest methods like popping popcorn I
have a favorite problem I do to get
these no look I actually have a problem
I love a stripper you didn't it's
addiction thanks for watching this was
very very interesting I can't believe
that I gave it away
everyone can free I mean it puffed
millet I'm like I don't you know what I
don't play I don't know
I'm gonna pose any other videos you
would like to see me make this is my
sister Jenna I'll put her link in the
description go to check out her YouTube
channel
I'm the millet master she
my next on just seen and Jenna cooks
what they fill it we're gonna we should
puff millets no I'm not that sounds like
something it's gonna get demonetised
whoa t monetized okay by our post Mintz
is here no it's already here the food is
sitting on the floor mama
I taste like a waffle
[Music]